Matt Healy responded to the backlash for
all the comments that he made on that
podcast and his response was surprising
a few months ago when Matt Healy was on
the Adam Freightliner Show podcast he
laughed at a bunch of racist jokes about
I spice they called her a bunch of
things like a chubby Chinese lady and
Matt Haley would laugh at it the guys on
the podcast also mocked Hawaiian and
Chinese accents and then Matt encouraged
them to imitate what a Japanese person
working in a concentration camp would
sound like and he also admitted to
pleasure himself to hardcore content of
black women getting brutalized and after
getting dragged for like the past week
he finally responded in a new interview
with the New Yorker and he basically
said that the whole thing doesn't really
matter and that no one really cares
about what he said and then he said that
people who were offended by his comments
were either delusional or lying about
being offended and then he basically
claimed that people are pretending to be
outraged that they can claim moral
superiority over him and other people it
was a very shocking response probably
one of the worst ways he could have
responded to this and now he's receiving
backlash with this response as well